a partir de este miércoles polonia ya no
cuenta con el gas natural ruso las
autoridades polacas dicen que fueron
informadas de la suspensión por gazprom
el martes por la noche el contrato de
varsovia con el gigante energético
estatal ruso le permitía a polonia
importar hasta 10 mil millones de metros
cúbicos de gas natural al año la mitad
de sus necesidades totales el primer
ministro polaco asegura que hay
suficientes reservas para hacer frente
al corte
nuestro almacenamiento de gas está lleno
en un 76 por ciento eso es un nivel
elevado mucho más alto que en la mayoría
de los países europeos por lo tanto
también en este periodo de transición
antes de que se ponga en marcha el
gasoducto del báltico podremos recurrir
a nuestros recursos
la decisión de cortar el suministro se
produce después de que polonia se negara
a pagar a gazprom en rublos así como la
medida de varsovia de sancionar a 50
entidades y funcionarios rusos por la
invasión de ucrania por parte de moscú
el ministro de energía búlgaro también
dijo que le habían comunicado el martes
sobre la suspensión de suministro de gas
ruso que representa el 90 por ciento de
las necesidades del país una sorpresa
para el cercano aliado de rusia
es un anuncio inesperado sobre todo
porque desde que comenzó la guerra en
ucrania bulgaria ha querido andar con
cuidado en torno a su hermano mayor ruso
por ejemplo ha evitado entregar armas a
ucrania
moscú había advertido en marzo a sus
clientes que se arriesgaban a que se les
cortara el suministro de gas si no
pagaban en rublos hungría es el único
país de la unión europea que aseguró que
cumpliría se teme que gazprom pueda
cortar el suministro a otros países lo
que podría causar dificultades
económicas a europa